hello everyone i'm maurice samuels the
director of the yale program for the
study of anti-semitism and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you today to our
benjamin and barbara zucker lecture
series i'm pretty sure this is our first
lecture on the topic of anti-semitism in
south america
the plan for today will be that i will
introduce the speaker he'll talk for
about 40 minutes and then we'll open it
up to questions from the audience
please submit your questions at any time
during the lecture using the q a
function at the bottom of your screen
and i will ask them
the chat function is disabled so don't
use that
today's speaker emanuel kahan holds a
phd in history and memory studies from
the national university of la plata
buenos aires and he's a researcher at
the national council for scientific and
technological research koniset in
argentina he's also a professor in the
history department at the national
university of la plata and teaches
postgraduate courses in different higher
education institutions throughout
argentina he's the academic coordinator
of the jewish studies program at the
institute for economic and social
development in buenos aires as well as
the education program for teachers on
the holocaust and other 20th century
genocides within the national plan for
teachers education in argentina he's
also an affiliated researcher at the
center for advanced genocide research at
the showa foundation at usc
he's the author of several books in
spanish on topics ranging from the
jewish experience during argentina's
military dictatorship to the
israel-palestine conflict in argentina
as well as one book in english memories
that lie a little published by brill in
2018.
in 2013 he received the american jewish
studies association's best dissertation
award and in 2015 he was awarded the
scientific work prize by the national
university of la plata
the title of his talk today is
anti-semitism in argentina historical
experience public debate and changing
meanings please join me in welcoming
emmanuel
thank you maurice samuels thank you
everybody for being here
and caring for listen to me and
you know i am from argentina english is
not my language so i apologize for some
mistakes i'm going to to make i'm going
to do
and
i'm going to uh to share my my screen
with some i have some slides to to
present so um
please
i think that now we are seeing the the
presentation
um
well
some years ago in the framework of a
conference on latin american jewish
studies
eyewitnesses a series of debates about
how to approach the jewish experience in
our region
in one of the exchange a researcher
working from aboard on the experience of
jewish life in argentina warned quote
however reviews the bibliography on the
history of argentina and jewish
community could conclude that the life
of jews in the country since they wake
up until they go back to sleep it's an
ordeal
anti-semitism is a widespread practice
that threatens their existence
however those of us who know the
development of institutional life as
well as unaffiliated issues we know that
is not the case end of quote
with a bit of grace this statement
challenged one of the perspectives that
had been central to the development on
the synonymization of fields of jewish
studies itself research on anti-semitism
in my country had revealed a concrete
and significant experience of the jewish
life in argentina but
in turn they had cemented a distorted
image about the integration of jews into
political social economic and cultural
life in my country
a contemporary look at anti-semitism in
my country could not fail to notice at
least three dimensions
in the first place it's conditioned as a
modern historical experience that even
when it is a global phenomenon has
situated in prince
second
the reception used and circulations of
anti-semitism in argentina has
particular characteristics a long
history that mobilizes a white group of
actors and that materialized in a series
of events of events of criminal scopes
the tragic week in 1919 the closure of
huge of jewish schools during the 30s
the attacks persecutions and murders
promoted by right-wing catholic
nationalist organizations in the 60s and
60s
the special treatment of the jewish
detains during the last dictatorship
and finally the terrorist attack against
the israel of israelite mutual
association of argentina amia in 1994
third the formation as a consequence of
the foregoing of a white and deeper
series of organizations that devote
themselves at each time to denouncing
antisemitic speech and practices
the course of these organizations can be
rebelling at times their strategies for
denouncing anti-semitism were one of the
engines of recognition in the public
space of the uniqueness of the jewish
experience in the country
but at the same time they were able to
hold the speech confronting the victims
of the persecutions against them
these presentations this presentation
aimed to prioritize these last two
dimensions through a series of presses
referenced based on the existing
biographic review and the survey of
documents resulting from my research on
the buenos aires police intelligence
reports at the consultation of
collections of the on the experience of
life jewish during the last military
dictatorship
the work of daniel bovich investigates
the origin of an anti-semitic narrative
since the end of 19th century among
actors ascribed to argentine catholic
nationalism
this study let us know the effects that
these early representations had on the
construction of an enemy within the
nationalist discourse that had its
heyday between 1932 and 1943
the appearance of these ideas and
proposals around the jewish question
accompanied the process of origin and
consolidation of a nationalist discourse
of a restrictive and authoritarian type
in opposition to the liberal and
integrating discourse that the ruling
classes the
elites had in the last third of the 19th
century
this nationalist discourse
was have strong links with the catholic
church and with sectors of the argentine
army forces that would link the idea of
nationality to the catholic religion
catholic sorry
the reception of the
dreifu's affair sorry at the end of 19th
century was a starting point around the
dissemination of conspiracy theories
about jewish by argentine consolities
it will be on the characterization of
the meat of the word jewish conspiracy
that the common denominator of argentina
and restricted nationalism was
consecrated
this theory made it possible to
articulate in the same speech the fear
of particular enemy the jews
the attacks on liberal democracy and the
demonization of the communist danger as
well as of english imperialism
also the effects of these speech around
mass mobilization probably limited
quote
the recurring use and the political and
literacy works that they inspired their
use in the political speeches and select
an electoral weapon the fact that they
have circulated in the forces armies and
above all the violent practices that is
inspired show that this influence in
farm is far from being marginal end of
quote
these narratives accompany a series of
practices that prove ominous for jewish
in argentina the tragic week in 1919
considered the first program in south
america left an uncertainty of victims
and the consecration of the figure of
the russian the jews
as a political agitator
the massacre against the jews in
balbanera neighborhood took place in the
context of the repression of the basena
factory strike
the repression on the jewish quarter of
buenos aires was justified by deeply
rude belief among the elites and the
petite bourgeois about the jewish
character of the revolution that were
taking place in europe and from now on
the incipient union of soviet
socialistic republics
anti-semitism will constitute
science
since then and at least until 80s and
90s
one of the ideological supports of
conservative nationalists and catholic
catholic sectors in my country
however not all nationalists
conservatives and catholics support
antisemitis but
as the authors who have dedicated
themselves to the study of right-wing
organizations were
narratives of hatred towards use were
found by the express within this
universe of programmatic perspectives
its weight among the elites and state
officials in various governments was
make was marking the pulse of a series
of provisions tending to restrict the
activities of the various choice
organizations as well as to homogenize
the population in relation to catholic
apostolic and roman worship
in this sense the closure of the jewish
working-class schools during the 30s or
the introduction of the compulsory
teaching of catholic catholic religion
with the military government in 1943 may
be illustrative of how this imprint
operated operated
at this point is necessary to replace
one of the classic debates both in the
field of political representations as
well as among historians the allegedly
antisemitic character of peronism
it is a controversy that as the work of
andreas visa point out
was contemporary to the emergence of the
movement led by juan domingo peron
his trajectory linked to nationalist
sectors that declared themselves neutral
during the development of the second
world war
associated the figura the figure of
general perron with european fascism
since then since then a recurring
narrative has been structured that
intends to represent peronism as a kind
of cruel narcissism
however the works of run and reign
have tried to show that the expansion of
citizenship rights instrument by the
perineus regime also had positive impact
on the jewish who inhabited inhabiting
the country
their works showed that the government
led by peyron did not promote any
measures against the jews and was even
very attentive to the demands made by
the community leaders in fiber of for
example facilitating the entry of
holocaust survivors or regular sites
regularizing their citizenship status
recognizing the state of israel or
censoring antisemitic statement
published by nationalist leaders
however
however
and even for the spiritual evidence
present by reigns works allowed to
corroborate his hypothesis
the perspective presented among others
by juan ruiz vysoki
work on the bernie's right cannot be
neglected
the terror genius character peronism and
its rhodes social programmatic and
ideological base
sheltered various sectors of catholic
and right-wing nationalists that were
deeply anti-semitic
the period after pernics will register
an increase of its circulation of
antisemitic speech treats and practices
leonardo segment produced one of the
most prominent pioneering and systematic
volumes on antisemitism during this
period highlighting some of the central
futures during the 90s during the 60s
and 70s
first
a continuing narrative could be
identified upholding the geological
produce of previous decadas decades the
jews were both the promoters of social
revolution and financial speculation
but to which was added the accusation of
double double loyalty
after the creation of the state of
israel in 1948
the nationalist organization questioned
the identification solidarity and
financing campaigns that various jewish
organizations and prominent prominent
personalities developed to support the
new state
organizations such as movimientonarista
tacquada and guardia restaurants
were the spearhead of a series of
campaigns that produced widespread fear
among jewish organizations and political
activists
different attack against edgardo
trinique in 1960 gracila sirota in 1962
and the murder of raul alderman in 1964
among the most prominent are
illustrative not only of the antisemitic
escalation of those ears but also of the
process of radicalization of political
violence that would characterize
subsequent years in argentina
this context must take into account the
reception of the arab israeli conflict
that mobilized a broader set of factors
and would give new and changing
arguments to the discourse against jews
during the period
if during this first half of the 60s the
accusation of double loyalty would have
the greatest impact after the six day
war in
1967 the criticisms would be placed on
the imperialist character of israel in
the middle east
this dimension however is complex
not all the actors and organizations
that denounce the israeli territorial
expansion in the world context can be
described described as antisemitic but
many others took advantage of the
climate of reject or rejection
of the world to legitimize in this
public space their positions against the
jews
turn
returning to segment work one of the
most outstanding aspects of his analysis
is that he indicates that the spiral of
anti-semitic violence did not
necessarily respond to the
characteristic of the political and
government regimes of the period
what does mean
that also there was has been a tendency
to think that dictatorships were fertile
ground for the emergence of the
anti-semitic narratives and practice
the detailed study of the proliferation
of freeze and attacks shows that their
increase was during the terms of
democratic governments
from
1958 to 1956
and from 1973
19
in particular this last period was very
profuse in public demonstration of a
rejection of the of rejection of the
shoes
these parts with a dispute with within
the ruling party during the third
bernie's promote a series of narratives
questioning the representation of jews
and their influences in the source of
government the business war the cultural
and intellectual field and political
militancy
following the death of juan domingo
peron in 1974 for example
his minister of social welfare joseo
perrega
deployed a public ambulant campaign
against the minister of finances jose
bergel which was largely based on his
status as a jew
the presence of jose helbert in the
ministry of economy during the
administrations of campora and perron
had been the cause of accusations by the
right-wing nationalist organizations
about the jewish infiltrations in power
and imperialism
in the same context
two episodes related to the conflict in
the middle east took place with
wheat as during the six day war once
again precipitated the question of
israel and zionists in the public debate
the yom kippur war in 1973 and the
declaration of the united nations
organizations equating zionists as a
kind of racism in 1975.
the reception of both events serve
antagonist sectors of the local
political descent on the right and on
the left
to challenge those who identified
themselves as truth incorporating into
the rhetoric of the war jewish plot the
accusation about the colonial dimension
of israel in the context of the cold war
in this sense the period characterizates
by radicalization of political violence
cases correlate in the produce against
the jews of many of the political
organizations attacked in those years
the military the military dictatorship
inaugurated on march 24 19
1976 was characterized unlike the other
dictatorial regimes that took place in
argentina during the 20th century
by a white displaced repressive policy
whose balance was 30 000 disappeared
people
500 appropriate children and a
significant number and of exercise and
political prisoners
the neighbor again report prepared by
the national commission of the on the
disappearance of person la conadep and
the report nuncamas
promoted by the democratic government of
fraud alfonsin
established that the greatest number of
victims had concentrated concentrated on
certain strata of society young people
workers professionals leaders
politicians and trade unions
and that among the universe of effect
there was in addition a special
treatment on the part of the
perpetrators towards the individuals who
were identified as jews
this representation of you as a special
victim of the last military military
dictatorship was forged early and
contemporaneously with the authoritarian
regime in 1976
on september 28 1976 bart levinson
representative of the anti-defamation
link of the name of the bene brit from
latin america present his testimony
before a commission of the chamber of
deputies of the united states of america
on human rights in argentina
during his statement he point out the
large number of nazi publications that
circulate in argentina and also allowed
to the fact that several deaths and in
terrorist attacks and of people who had
disappeared were the jewish descent
levison's pronouncement started
controversy around who had legitimacy to
denounce what was happening and to what
extent anti-semitism was a component of
the policies that the dictator regime
carried out in the so-called fight
against against against supervision
the first voice that would be raised
against the representative of the
anti-defamation league
would be that of a journalist who would
later recognize himself as a victim of
repression jacob timmerman
however was the director of opinion will
send a letter to north american senator
donald fraser on october 1 1967
66-76 his capacity as chairman of the
subcommittee that deals with the issue
of human rights in my country
holding a different view of the
declaration of levinson quote
my newspaper opinion
had dealt with this problem human rights
at all times
trying to do so
trying to do so obstetrically without
partiality concern about the human
rights of all the countries inhabitants
in the same spirit i feel obligated to
point out to you the danger of hearing
partial testimonies which i believe is
happening in that subcommittee
the opinion has condemned all violence
and on several occasions has stressed
that condemning only one of the extremes
be it terrain from the left or from the
right means being an accomplice of the
of the other extreme
this leads me dear mr fraser to ask you
to be invited to testify before that
subcommission
in the conviction that my testimony will
serve to understand the human rights of
the entire argentina population without
exclusions
and to prevent an unnecessary
deterioration of relations between our
two countries
end of quote
timmerman's request would be paradoxical
he could classify years later as
collaborators those who had the same
attitude or refuse to consider the
nature of their arrest as a part of
anti-semitic campaign by the military
dictatorship dictatorship
however the controversy as a result of
levinson's statement shows that the
jewish question was a sensitive vector
of international complaints about human
rights violations in our country
the analysis the analysis of documents
found a law has to identify two
distinctive forms of manifestations of
anti-semitism in the ethical period
one of a public nature and the other of
a clandestine
while the first was characterized by the
commercial dissemination of liberty
against jews treats an attack against
community institutions and even the
official attempt to impound the
compulsory teaching of a catholic
religion in public education
the second materialistic more diffuse
the anti-semitism of the clandestine
order refers to the ways in which the
treatment of the jews was administrated
in the clandestine detention centers and
the various penitentiary units where the
political prisoners were houses housed
under the disposition of the national
executive power
in this sense it could be note that the
public anti-semitism was one of the
central concerns that continued to
mobilize mobilize the authorities of the
argentinian jewish community and that
obtained positive response from the
dictatorial authorities
editorials were close numbers were sized
and anti-semitic books from stores for
sale to the public
rabbis were incorporated into television
programming closures the holocaust
series was broadcast and so on
however the scope for action around
anti-semitism of the clandestine order
proved narrow and not very permanently
for the representatives of institutions
of the jewish community
the centrally
the centrality that the issue of special
treatment of jew had in the period of
democratic recovery and the debates
around the identification of the crimes
of the dictatorships with the holocaust
can be weighed by the effect they had on
actors of national and nationalist
rights
as the work of jorge saborido and
matthias greenput the greenspun show the
first years of democracy replenished in
the public space anti-semitic
representations and representations that
accuse the issues of being behind a new
government led by raul fonsin and of the
persecution of those responsible for the
crimes that committed during the
military dictatorship
also the eighties are still a period of
little work the
aforementioned investigations allow us
to know the continued nature of the
anti-semitic discourse during these
years
also there is still no research to
confirm this
we could suggest that until the attacks
on the embassy of israel in 1992 and the
asian mutual israelite argentina in 1994
anti-semitism as public rhetoric and
practice of nationalist catholic and
conservative groups it maintained a
certain capacity to mobilize sense or
precipitate polemics in public space
however after the tax social sensitivity
around the representations of the issue
in public space changed
this consideration of the
reconfiguration of anti-semitism after
the army bombing would not only be a
mere declarative question but a
meteorological premise for those of us
who investigate the development of
argentina and jewish life in recent
history
why
a glance at the contemporary scene
cannot fail to notice that the
integration of jews in the various
dimensions that make up the public's
fair has been in some sense successful
unlike the debates and attacks that took
place during match of the 20th century
the years we are going through show
various personalities with different
degrees of self-identification with the
jewish occupying central functions of
the of the institutional state cultural
and political fields
the same could be said in relation to
the business sphera
for some time now the question about the
persecution or accusations against the
jews has been losing weight
in any case
controversies emerge when the topics put
israel israel or the middle east in the
center
this shift in meaning is consistent with
the impact that the demonization of
anti-semitism has on the public agenda
does this mean that there is not
anti-semitism in my country no not at
all
but it's evident but it's even evident
that there is a broad acceptance of an
integration of individuals of jewish
origin in various stars of national in
the war that at times cast duped on the
effectiveness of the campaigns to
denounce the persecution and hatred of
jewish developed by local community
institutions and international
organizations
anti-semitic expressions that have
occurred in the country since the
beginning of the 20th century are more
like
caricatured versions of the
interventions and the impact that those
sumner that that do same narratives had
during much of the 20th century
it seems that anti-semitism is less
enlightened freed to the extent to the
existence of jewish life in the country
as it could be happening for example in
some european countries where its
situation is warring that there are
resources for intervention and
legitimation in the public space
national and in the network of
transnational relations of institutions
and organizations that have a
representative representation
aspirations of the jews
analysis of the positions of the
representative entities of jews in
argentina could be illustrative of how
they seek to preserve or reproduce
identity mechanisms that tend to mute a
unit a group even against the very big
teams of anti-semitism that they propose
to confront
in 1919 for example during the tragic
week rabbi alfon from the israelite
congregation of argentine republic
warned president e-policy reduction that
marxist jews we are were elements
outside the community
we we could point out the same in
relation to the military dictatorship
and the confrontation established by the
organization of relative or jewish
victims of state terrorism
or more tragically
the distance resistance and opacity of
the community leadership to deal with
the relatives of the victims of the army
bonding
a study of the narratives practices and
interventions of institutions dedicated
to denouncing anti-semitism should not
necessarily conclude
sorry
conclude
that they seek to defend protect or
represent or represent those effect by
anti-semitism in argentina
thanks
thank you uh so much for that really
interesting talk and i think that we'll
have um
an interesting discussion now so i i ask
everyone to uh please submit questions
using the q a uh
um
function and i will
get us started i was wondering if you
could um
start by giving us a sense of
the ethnic makeup of argentina so how
many jews are there what percentage of
the population is jewish and what are
the other um
ethnic groups uh in ireland
okay maurice well that's interesting
point because
uh argentina has the
the most
bigger the strong community jewish
community in latin america
um
i mean it's a
biggest in
in a demographic sense but at the same
time in a i mean in a symbolic
sense too why because um well we have
many jewish in in my country but most of
them there are living in the most
important cities of the of argentina
buenos aires cordoba mendoza rosario la
plata
and so they came to the country uh
during the the the
the big immigration immigration process
in the 19th century and they in
integrated i said uh
during all the 20th century
uh
and
introduced
then and the
and the right organizations to uh the
the the debates the the debates about
the huge question about around all this
earlier century so um
it's an it's an important discussion
it's an important community
but at the same time
it's bigger but it's in proportion it's
not really big i mean it's about now
two
two thousand uh yes two hundred thousand
uh maybe two two hundred two hundred
fifty
thousand uh
hundred thousand uh
used in maybe in the 60s there are more
but i mean it's it's a less than one
percent of the of the population but at
the same time they have a really uh um i
mean
uh they they are
well known as a as a great community in
in my country
and how um
you know how can you compare the the um
anti-semitism to prejudice against other
immigrant communities um in argentina so
was there also like
anti-italian uh sentiment in the 20th
century
uh or because they were catholic
was there less no
no that that's interesting too because
if you saw what happened during the
first part of the 20th century i mean
the first 30 years and this
discrimination was
was put on jewish obviously but at the
same time in italians or some part of
some kind of spain
people who
get into to my country uh why because
well they're catholic too but they have
different uh languages or they use this
they use different traditions so and
when you saw what happened in the
scholarly system
for example uh you you're going to found
not me but people that studied the this
the situation they still
they they found that the discrimination
it's around all the immigration during
during the period
but at the same time
this this kind of immigration the
italian the spanish immigration
they integrate more easily easily and
more quickly i don't know is is the word
but the jewish the questions the body
the polemics around the jewish continued
around all the early 20th century
but now i think it's because you
certainly what happened in the the
beginning of the 20th century but i i
want to say what happened now because
the discrimination now is not
only the they didn't it doesn't have the
the jews in the center of the tibet they
have what happened with other
populations that came from
countries that are near argentina
bolivia peru paraguay maybe so
discriminations continue but the the
people that are discriminated are others
than the jews
okay and we're getting a lot of
questions from the audience but i have
one more question of my own
and then i'll come to those so can you
characterize um
the um
uh well the response of the jewish
community in argentina um to
anti-semitism and also the nature of the
the community would you say that it's
more insular compared to the united
states like the rates of intermarriage
for instance are they similar to the
united states do you know or
uh i i remember that uh
i i i well
er
more maybe the the most important uh
organizations of the jewish community in
my country had the strong policies uh
around the the anti-semitism and
historical you know the the beginning of
the day the the the political
representation of the community in my
country
is
in relation with the denounce of nazi
fascism during the 30s in the country uh
but at the same time they have this uh
i mean these arms uh
to fight against the anti-anticipation
but at the same time they have another
policies
in relation with the continuity the
continuity of the judaism in in the
country so
i remember when i was young
a lot of debates about this kind of
marriage and what happened with judeans
and all the debates about the what the
jews have to do if they have to live
here go to israel and i mean there these
are part of the jewish the jewish
community but but as
another researchers said not all the
jewish in my country are integrated to
the jewish institutions i i mean
maybe that's that's a more
uh
it's it's more similar than what
happened in the u.s
okay so question from the audience um
can you compare
um the rate of art of anti-semitism
today in argentina to anti-semitism in
other latin american countries um is
there more anti-semitism would you i
mean there are definitely more jews in
argentina yeah there's also more
anti-semitism in argentina compared to
other places
yeah yeah other places in latin america
yeah uh oh well really i i i i really
didn't know what happened in all the
countries of america you know that
america is very very particular it's
very big and it's very
um
they have many countries are different
countries too um but i think that they
you're going to found if you look um
issue each country you're going to find
some
special characteristics
in each one i mean argentina has like
you said like like you said the biggest
jewish community and the question of the
anti-semitism and the quiz and the
jewish question is um
they they
they move some sensibility in the in the
public space but um
if you look what happened in chile uh
when the palestinian community is very
big yes the anti-semitism there maybe
it's more strong i mean the the
the bds campaigns in argentina really
they didn't have um
how how how can you say they didn't have
a quick route there yes and what
happened in chile is the opposite yes
they really their biggest there yeah and
and maybe um something seamless happened
i don't know what happened now in mexico
but um and brazil is it's a it's a
different case because well uh you know
now uh
the debates about the bolsonaro regime
and what the position about between
bolsonaro and israel uh it's it's it's
particular so the the the situation
about anti-semitism and and israeli
it's very very special
i think that the
the
science since
this era this new this new century the
the question of israel uh and the middle
east conflict uh
is in the middle of the of the debate uh
about the anti-semitism in our countries
too i think that's the same in the u.s
and what happened in europe too now
um
so
another question about um the nature of
right-wing anti-semitism in argentina
over the course of the 20th century this
is another comparative question so
is it that different from
right-wing
anti-semitism in france say or in
other countries or is it part of the
same kind of um thing would you say no
really i think that you you you present
a good example because
uh as daniel uh told in in
his study uh
the the
the argentine the creole uh
anti-semitism
it's a it's a kind of copy of french
anti-semitism i mean most of the of the
the the the biggest the or the first uh
books of uh anti-semitism
in my country are maybe copies of that
that
marcel dumont
wrote on france on the final of the 20
on the 19th century and then you are
going to found some relations between
what happened in french and in in
argentina in argentina too um
and i think that the uh
this kind of
nationalists right-wing
are maybe in relation as uh
other researchers uh shows uh
renatoslavsky shows that they have some
networks that some international
networks that they introduce ideas books
uh and they
they support
i think the the anti-semitism narratives
as part of this of the of their
practices
and um okay so going back to um
uh the point you made in the talk about
um
anti-semitism under the dictatorship and
uh you know how there was a higher a
large percentage of the disappeared were
jews can you just say can you elaborate
on that why why was that uh can you say
more i felt like that was a
key point in your presentation and i
think people are fascinated and would
love to hear more
yeah yes that's a very interesting point
and it's very polemic because
it's really that if you if you
look what happened with the jewish
descended
jewish people of jewish origin in in my
country during the dictatorship you are
going to find that many
2 000 or 1
500
people of the jewish origin disappear in
in this period and the the number of
disappear are 30 000
you know um
but
it's like the five percent of the of the
disappears are jewish
uh
but not
the five percent of the population of
francina are jews so you have there yes
yes yes you have their some problem uh i
think that we
we can
found two
two two answers for that
the first one uh maybe is that um
three answers the first one is
we have anti-semitism in our country
during the 20th century that is real
first
the second is
the the the
people that disappear in this period are
most of them professionals students
political leaders
and the jewish are integrated in this
in these strategies so
the the number
maybe show the the process the
successful process of integration of the
jewish to the
national life
and third one maybe the most problematic
answer is that the people that are
detained but the policies by the
policies forces or the army forces
during this period uh are detained by
by
her
polity political identity not her
ethnic or religious
identity so
you are going to found really
1500 jewish disappear 2 000 jews
disappear
yes but they are not in the clandestine
centers uh because they are jew they are
there because they are part of the uh
left parties or
army organizations
the revolutionary army organizations so
um
we we we have to to to understand what
are what is happening during all this
period when when i said all these
periods what happened during the 60s the
70s uh and how the the youth the youth
jews
integrate to the political life in my
country
okay um this is a kind of difficult
question um so can you expand on
the different positions taken by the
official argentine jewish leadership
and some american jewish
organizations such as the bene brit
during the dictatorship and do you think
that those differences between argentine
and american jewish organizations
um
uh persists today in relation to current
anti-semitism
oh uh
i i oh the question about what happened
today it's more it's more problematic
for me because i'm a historian i have
all my my tools for understanding what
happened in the past but uh really i am
very confused in the present and the the
present is very hard
and
um
i think that the the situation
between the different uh responses of
the of the institutional uh leaders in
in argentina and and in the us during
the the
dictatorship uh
it's about the different views or the
different possibilities that they have
in
in
in in each context um
i mean i i use the the quote of jacob
timmerman because he's a well-known
journalist that they was victim of
deterrence of the state terrain during
this period but in 1976 they
support the dictatorships and they
attack the the people in the u.s that
they say that here the regime are
are uh how how
how i come to say are fighting the human
rights uh
in
in in the country uh and
and and maybe
they saw that because they are looking
all the situation uh during the 60s and
the 17th and what happened in israel or
in the us
are that institutional like the
anti-inflammation league the american
jewish committee
or maybe other organizations the embassy
of
yes the foreign the ministry of foreign
affairs of israel tried to support to
help people that are suffering the human
regulations in in my country um
i i think that uh
that now
i don't know what happened now in the
u.s but now the the the jewish
leaderships in in my community are
involved in political
i mean in political debates
maybe of the most
many of the of the
of the leaders of the community are now
in importing parties in in in my country
so
they they make more confused the
situation about how
did use the the the nonce of
antisemitism in the in the in the
present uh and really that's the problem
you know that that's interesting because
if you saw what happened with the with
the army bombing you have a lot of
organizations and family of relatives of
of
of
people who die in the in the bombing
that are not
in relation with the army
leadership so
there you have the
problem so to kind of follow up on the
um bombing
uh very interesting question that you
know so that bombing in 1994 someone
points out killed 85 people and is the
largest terrorist attack in argentina
yeah so does the fact
that 27 years later we still don't know
who was responsible does that reflect
anti-semitism at some level of uh
society
oh uh
in a way yes sure um
as as many many
researchers
shows um
the the
solidarity of the population uh after
the the bombing it's very strong uh but
at the same time we have to explain what
happened with this uh this judicial
process that
they never finished and
we didn't know who who were the author
of the of the bombing of the tank and
that's it's a kind of anticipation yes
really we can say that but at the same
time maybe it is a um
its expression of the uh
the the
the ability i don't know if he's
i mean the opposite of strong of the uh
institutional democracy in my country
yeah because uh you we we don't know
what happened with the bombing but we we
have many processes in relation with
with this attack i mean what happened
with the
the die of uh
the the persecutor nisman and what
happened with the and
any any any any process process judicial
process are resolved so maybe these are
talking about
this label uh institutional democracy
with that we have okay interesting
um so
a question about um
academia uh yeah
so um
you know
we've observed in the united states
there's an increasing presence of bds
and of anti-israel anti-zionist um
activity on college campuses that a lot
of people are very concerned about um
could you just tell us what it's like um
on campuses in argentina is there is the
bds movement strong do you feel
um is there a lot of anti-zionist uh
pressure right now oh
yes oh well this is the different
situation in argentina as i said uh in
the in the in the other question about
what happened in chile maybe um
i mean here you are going to have people
that support the bds and uh and have
an anti-zionist narrative
position but really they are not not
strong in in the country i think that
we have many many particular
characteristics uh in in in
in argentina one is what happened with
the army [ __ ] with what happened with the
jewish disappearing during the
dictatorships they build a
representation
acceptance by the social
uh
the the the
the population about the jews as a
victim of the of the dictatorship then
you have the bombing going in
israel embassy and then in amia in 1994
so
maybe
this kind of practices and narratives
have no
organizations they are not very strong
and
they're marginal now but they they live
they have
places here and
maybe
in
when when some when something happens in
in in middle east in israel between
palestine and other countries in
i mean lebanon or syria or egypt uh well
did the debate introduce uh this the the
introduce or legitimize these positions
but then they they move uh on the
marching again and
nothing happens i mean i know some some
colleagues of the us of the uh israel
that they have some problems in chile
for gift classes or the same in
in
in israel in mexico but in argentina
that's not that's not happened that's
interesting because you know i i think
that there's such a strong kind of um
you know
traditional lefty leftist um presence in
argentina so i'm that's that's
interesting that the
anti-zionism isn't necessarily part of
that um yeah
one one thing more
argentina is
the only one
country of latin america that is part of
the
international holocaust alliance
remnants alliance the ira so
they have a strong
they have a strong police policies on
holocaust remembrance and commemoration
and education so maybe
you have here some some uh interesting
points to to to analyze for understand
why bds or anti-scionists are not
they exist but are not really strong
interesting and is there um compulsory
holocaust education in public schools in
argentina
do you think this is a holocaust yeah
yeah yeah we have an uh what we have a a
a
new law it's not new because it's about
the beginning of the of the 21 century
about uh they introduced the human
rights uh as a as a
a great
you know a great field in education and
we have some
some resolutions of the national
minister of education that introduced
the holocaust
learning of holocaust the study of
holocaust in schools and we we have them
we made i make it really i do it
i make the books for for the holocaust
for for the training teachers
on holocaust
studies or holocaust education so we
have the
books we made books we made some videos
and it's interesting too last week we
have an activity with spain which is a
separate center of spain
because the materials that argentina
produce about the holocaust and
genocides during the 20th century are
the only ones in spanish and as you know
the spanish spanish is a language that
we speak in latin america but the us now
is the second community of spanish
people in spanish we're talking about
this in in in all the world so maybe we
can
use
we can um
share this these books for spain and for
all latin america that's great
so
you know i think we we have been
witnessing and i think this is a
trend that's continuing a kind of
depopulation of jews um from
which would be from many countries in
the world to either the united states
and israel um
you know and um
if i'm not wrong i think argentina is
maybe
still the fourth or fifth biggest jewish
population in the world i mean i think
maybe after france and the so
i think that that now is the the feast
the feast
yes the fifth uh bigger population
jewish population in the world yes
and most of them lives in buenos aires
so when i say it's
it's strange because it's argentina but
at the same time it's one society
you know that's the case in france too
where you know the jewish population of
france as a whole is small as you know
like under one percent but in paris it's
actually very big and that's the capital
of the jews
so but do you um and this is maybe you
know it's hard to forecast the future
but
do you see that the the community
continuing in argentina or are we seeing
a kind of increase in immigration to
israel or to the united states among
jews in argentina or is it do you
[Music]
think oh oh it's
it's interesting i mean i have some
problems to analyze the present i said i
am historian but i i really it's more
difficult to me what
look what is going to happen
in the future now but uh it's
interesting because as a
colleague
should be boxer lieberman a colleague of
a national university of mexico uh nam
uh it says something interesting and
search the pergola of jerusalem
university too it shows that maybe
jewish
life in in the 21st century it's more
uh
a process of already exploration i mean
are not people that are going just only
to israel maybe
more people are going to
the us not not jewish people in
argentina are thinking that the us it's
one of the of the options but at the
same time maybe are moving all around
the all around the world again and
i think a jewish community i think that
it's going to continue yes really but at
the same at the same that happen in uh
maybe in the us and maybe in mexico too
or
in chile or in uh uh the the the jewish
life is changing too because
i mean the process of integration and
now maybe the identification with israel
and
with the anti-semitism what that
happened now in europe is
making some movements in in the
representations about the identity
the self-identification about the
jewishness
okay so interesting um so we're about
out of time so i want to really thank
you on behalf of uh the audience who you
can't see but i will clap uh for
everybody uh here a kind of virtual
clapping and really say thank you for
sharing your your expertise and
knowledge um with us today we're really
really grateful and thank you to
everyone in the audience for coming make
sure to um look
at the uh ypsa the yale program for the
study of anti-semitism website sign up
for our um announcements for our email
list so you can um see what we have we
have a lot of really interesting
programming uh coming up uh next
semester so i look forward to uh seeing
you all again soon and thank you again
um so much emmanuel
thank you thank you very much